[Musica]
buonasera a tutti una piccola premessa
mi hanno chiesto di fare un intervento
inspiration o come si dice in gergo per
essere coerenti col con il tema con lo
spirito del ted ed è quello che ho
preparato ci sono diverse immagini che
vedrete che spero mi aiuteranno a
raccontare una storia questa storia
vi abbiamo incuriosito un pochino
spero di sì sono gli ultimi contadini e
le ultime contadine che abitavano le
nostre campagne e abitavano fino agli
anni 60 70
poi se ne sono andati hanno dovuto
abbandonare questi luoghi e hanno anche
un certo senso voluto abbandonare questi
posti quando è arrivata la modernità
sono persone che hanno scelto il
silenzio perché erano stanchi di una
vita molto dura e si vergognavano forse
anche un po di appartenere a questo
mondo così difficile il mondo rurale
sono persone che oggi vivono in mezzo a
noi sono gli anziani che troviamo seduti
nelle panchine a prendere il sole ei
vecchietti che vivono nelle villette di
periferia nei condomini
alcuni di loro ancora abitano dei
casolari sparsi sono persone che
comunque rappresentano una civiltà che
possiamo dire oggi definitivamente
scomparsa nel ventesimo secolo questo
mondo che loro hanno abitato non esiste
già più ringrazio un giovane fotografo
scolano alessio panichi per questa bella
foto che ci ha regalato è un vigneto del
piceno e dunque io li chiamo aborigeni
mezzadri adesso questo è il tema un po
provocatorio vorrei fare questo percorso
con voi
diciamo che il termine aborigeno è un
termine che si riferisce ad una figura
che nella storia dell'occidente
praticamente non è mai esistita
forse lo leghiamo più a quelle culture
indigene che abitavano o abitano tuttora
delle zone remote del nostro pianeta
dove si sviluppa un rapporto simbiotico
con la natura per la sopravvivenza
perché non esiste mercato perché non
esiste capitale perché si vive in
economia di sussistenza
gli aborigeni dovevano necessariamente
pensare a conservare il loro ambiente
dovevano pensare a mantenere in piedi un
equilibrio più lungo possibile per più
tempo possibile perché proprio
dalle risorse naturali dipendeva la loro
vita e dunque erano molto attenti a
prelevare il meno possibile e ad
applicare delle tecniche rigenerative
gli aborigeni e i mezzadri quindi i
nostri aborigeni mezzadri conoscevano il
segreto più intimo nella natura
la rigenerazione
quella che vedete è il logo di
un'agenzia mondiale una delle più famose
agenzie mondiali che si occupa di
sostenibilità e di economia e circolari
potete anche visitare il sito è molto
interessante attualmente in corso anche
un festival che può essere diciamo
partecipato online destructive festival
che ci parla proprio di questo mondo che
verrà di queste economie circolari e
della sostenibilità che dobbiamo
abbracciare la fondazione l mercantour
definisce un sistema autorigenerativo
come un sistema che restaura rinnova air
e vitalità le risorse energetiche e
materiali creando degli ambiti di
sostenibilità che integrano i bisogni
dell'uomo con quelli della natura questi
sistemi si definiscono anche olistici è
un termine difficile ma forse qualcuno
di voi l'ha già sentito un sistema
olistico è quello dove la somma delle
parti è sempre maggiore o al massimo
uguale alle parti che hanno costituito
il risultato finale che vuol dire che in
un sistema olistico non esistono scarti
nella quale nella catena del valore e
dunque l'economia circolare l'economia
mezzadrile sono entrambe accomunate dal
fatto di essere sistemi autori
generativi sistemi terapeutici nei
confronti della natura
sentiamo dunque i nostri contadini e
alle nostre contadine pensiamo a questi
anziani che dovevano passare questa vita
nella loro terra in campagna che
dovevano curare i boschi anche il
termine curare dovevano preoccuparsi del
suolo evitare l'erosione delle piogge
dovevano rieter tilizzare la terra
dovevano sostanzialmente confermare
questo ambiente nella miglior forma
possibile nella migliore salubrità
possibile perché da questo dipende va
la loro vita e dunque era un mondo
questo perfettamente circolare in questo
mondo
io ho come dire pensato di fare un
viaggio che questa l'idea che volevo
condividere con voi oggi perché ted
significa idee che vale la pena
condividere la mia idea è quella di
togliere questi contadini queste
contadine queste donne da questo ambito
del folklore dove per anni noi li
abbiamo relegati perché considerati
antichi desueti considerate figure del
passato interessanti si però insomma non
più di tanto no in realtà io vorrei fare
questo percorso a dimostrare che sono
degli ecologisti ante litteram
dimostrare che loro appartengono forse
più al nostro futuro
rispetto al presente perché ci aprono
gli occhi su uno scenario che forse noi
ancora non siamo riusciti ad abbracciare
non un mondo che dovrà venire che ancora
non ci appartiene completamente
per fare questo è necessario fare un
reportage
questa è la foto di una delle donne che
vivono attualmente nella valle del
fronte che non rinuncia pur essendo
passata dopo gli anni sessanta nel mondo
della modernità non rinuncia comunque
alle sue abitudini non una aborigena
metà è quindi necessario fare questo
viaggio all'interno di questa
popolazione a questi ultimi testimoni di
una civiltà scomparsa e
spero che questo sarà un percorso che si
potrà concludere nel più breve tempo
possibile perché voglio fare questo
perché penso che tutti noi siamo più o
meno consapevoli del fatto che il nostro
modello di vita non è più sostenibile
modello occidentale comunque qualche
problema ce l'ha questa figura
rappresenta un po diciamo nell'uomo
moderno alle prese con i problemi
l'inquinamento dell'aria del suolo il
riscaldamento del pianeta
il buco dell'ozono il cibo per non
parlare del cibo siamo ossessionati dal
cibo vorremmo sempre sapere con fa
mangiamo da dove viene
vorremmo essere sicuri di avere cibi
biologici
siamo preoccupati per la nostra salute
per la salute del pianeta
abbiamo poi delle relazioni umane un po
più povere di quello che forse noi
desidereremmo perché perché viviamo in
un buono nomade digitale siamo un po
spaesati insomma sappiamo che dobbiamo
cambiare ma come
parliamo un po di economia circolare un
tema che avevo introdotto anche prima
l'economia circolare abbiamo visto che è
un'economia della rigenerazione e anche
un'economia del riuso ma non abbiamo
detto che l'economia circolare si ispira
al mondo naturale mondo naturale che è
quello che adesso vi faccio brevemente
vedere in questo video per esempio di
uno stercoraro di un piccolo scarabeo
che utilizza il letame dei grandi
mammiferi per costruire la sua casa e
per alimentarsi e dunque in natura le
materie circolano da uno stato all'altro
senza generare rifiuti non ci sono
discariche in natura e come succede con
il mondo naturale anche nell'economia
circolare il primo principio ci insegna
che i rifiuti di una specie sono cibo
per un'altra specie dunque le cose
esseri nascono vivono muoiono poi
tornano alla terra e così tutto funziona
il mondo va avanti così e questo mondo
non è forse anche il mondo dei nostri
mezzadri in questo piccolo podere chiuso
dove non c'era mercato non c'è la
capitale non c'è un'economia dove si
doveva coltivare la terra per dare poi
al proprietario che lo aveva in gestione
il 50 per cento delle tue risorse
il mezzadro viveva in un mondo
naturalmente circolare a rifiuti zero
mondo che veniva da molto lontano veniva
dagli antenati
lui aveva a disposizione la sapienza la
conoscenza degli antenati degli antenati
degli antenati
pensiamo che addirittura nell'italia
centrale questo risale all'anno mille
primi contratti di enfiteusi dei monaci
benedettini che stipulavano con le
famiglie nullatenenti e dunque possiamo
dire che è così come quel famoso io
penso sia abbastanza famoso mito
africano del sun cofano che è
rappresentata da questo uccello che
guarda la coda o dal cuore arricciato
dell'indigeno giovane che va sulla riva
del fiume per attraversarlo e trovo una
canoa vecchia in polvere
la ruota e decide giovane di partire da
solo verso il suo mondo si accorge a
metà strada che deve tornare indietro a
prendere qualche attrezzo perché diciamo
non ce la poteva fare sankofa significa
torna indietro a trendy lì e anche nel
nostro mondo degli aborigeni i nostri
personalissimi aborigeni dell'italia
centrale
esisteva questo tempo che io chiamo il
tempo sospeso il tempo nel quale le
donne le nonne le figlie le mamme
bambini si raccontavano le memorie
condividevano questo sapere attraverso
gli stornelli attraverso le barzellette
attraverso le favole attraverso diamo
tutta quella narrativa che apparteneva
al mondo contadino e che si sviluppava
in un momento preciso il momento della
cura quando si stava in casa quando si
facevano le faccende domestiche quando
si acuivano gli anziani o piuttosto i
bambini questo tempo della cura tempo
sospeso il tempo della narrazione era il
tempo delle donne
le mamme le nonne di tentate anche le
nubili aggregate alla famiglia
mezzadrile e da queste donne è da qui
che io vi propongo di ripartire perché
le donne sono i custodi della saggezza
di un sapere senza tempo che forse ci
può aiutare a guardare il nostro futuro
grazie
es